un étage et demi d'activité d un étage
de fab lab un étage de bureau
aujourd'hui ils sont installés à magny
les hameaux demain les 250
collaborateurs de generix group
occuperont ce bâtiment à guyancourt
bubble one le futur siège multi usages
de ce cluster lancé en janvier 2019 le
chantier devrait se conclure en février
2020 on a souhaité donc être
propriétaire de l'immeuble pour être
donc à notre disposition de nos
activités et du projet de cluster de
pouvoir héberger des porteurs de projets
des des start up et puis bien évidemment
prendre en compte aussi l'évolution du
groupe qui est en croissance permanente
une croissance de près de 30% ce cluster
est composé de plusieurs start up
pluridisciplinaire engagés dans
l'innovation différentes infrastructures
sont prévues ce hall occupera une
plateforme d'intégration de systèmes sur
plusieurs types de véhicules des outils
conçus au premier étage on arrive dans
la zone bureau d'études pour concevoir
les produits qui sont fabriqués à
l'étagé en dessous au centre donc il est
prévu que l'on installe des zones de
travail collaboratives
nous avons donc essayé de placer un
certain nombre de salles de réunion et
on va jusque à la faune box qui permet
de faire une colle conférence soit 2
soit tout seul ou bien même prendre une
communication privée le cas échéant des
espaces flexibles multi-usages de
coworking de co-création d'open
innovation nous arrivons à la partie
belle femme donc la partie open
génération c'est une structure capable
de recevoir à la fois des clients qui
nous expriment des besoins recevoir des
porteurs de projets recevoir de start up
qui nous présentent leur technologie
enfin le toit du bâtiment va servir de
terrasse il est prévu aussi des
installations pour la consommation
énergétique du bâtiment s'est installé
un système solaire sur la toiture s'est
récupéré certes énergie solaire dans un
stockeur et se stocker restituera cette
énergie sur des bornes de voitures
électriques et dans l'infrastructure du
bâtiment près de six millions d'euros
ont été investis dans
projet humble tout est humble free
pourrait voir le jour dans les
prochaines années